c'est un géant des mers un fleuron de
l'industrie française qui en a
éclaboussé plus d'un en 1960 le france
sort des chantiers navals de saint
nazaire il est mise à l'eau sous lé
regard du général de gaulle qui veut en
faire un symbole de la puissance
française
[Musique]
c'est chose faite il y à 60 ans le 11
janvier 1962 sa construction terminée il
est inauguré par le premier ministre
michel debré quelques jours plus tard il
quitte son port d'attache du havre pour
sa première traversée direction les
canaries à son bord yvonne de gaulle
1443 passagers embarquent tôt havre le
19 janvier 1962 la fête commence sous le
regard amusé et bienveillant de la
marraine du navire madame 2 après cette
traversée pour roder les machines le
bateau s'élance pour la première fois
vers new york le 3 février 1962 france a
quitté le havre pour sa première
traversée vers new york gagnant la haute
mer le navire long de 315 mètres et
déplaçant 56 mille tonnes atteint
rapidement sa vitesse de croisière à
cette époque ce mastodonte des mers et
le plus grand paquebot du monde et pour
certains le plus beau visite guidée sur
le france où tout a été conçu pour le
confort et le bien-être le personnel de
la salle à manger des premières classes
achève la mise en place des tables pour
le déjeuner
la classe touriste qui peut accueillir
15 cents passagers est aussi bien
aménagé et décoré que la première classe
des tapisseries d'aubusson orne le fus
moi dans le grand salon des sièges
confortables un bar et une véranda
permettent à chacun de goûter les
plaisirs qu'ils préfèrent cinq jours
plus tard comme prévu le bateau arrive à
new york ils ont entre ainsi dans la
grande histoire des traversées
transatlantiques 8 février 1962 9 heures
du matin l'horaire a été strictement
respecté france entre dans l'hudson
river et va recevoir l'accueil
inoubliable que new york réserve aux
grands navires qui pénètre pour la
première fois dans son port
a répondu aux espérances mise en lui il
a répondu aux espérances mais il n'est
pas rentable l'état suspend ses
subventions il est désarmé en 1974
en 1979 le france est revendue il est
rebaptisé le norway et c'est sous les
yeux de milliers de havre et qu'il
quitte le port on est gros sur le coeur
qu'est ce qu'il représente ce bateau pro
russe était la plus belle unité de la
marine française après plusieurs
changements de propriétaire
le paquebot termine sa course ici au
monde en 2006 pour y être démantelé
la plus belle unité de la marine
française a terminé sa carrière dans le
plus grand cimetière marin au monde
[Musique]